>> Tucker: THANKS VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: LAST WEEK
LAWMAKERS IN GEORGIA PASSED
A BILL THAT TRIES TO BAN ALL
BIEWRGSES AFTER A FETAL
HEART BEAT CAN BE DETECTED
ABOUT SIX WEEKS IN THE
PREGNANCY.
SEEMS LIKE A COMPASSIONATE
THING TO DO.
NOT EVERYONE AGREED THOUGH.
ACTRESS ALYSSA MILANO SAYS
WOMEN SHOULD FIGHT BACK IN
THE BEDROOM.
LAST FRIDAY MILANO TWEETED
THIS:
AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST MARK
STEYN JOINS US TONIGHT.
SO, MARK, MESSAGE, YOU CAN'T
HAVE SEX WITH ALYSSA MILANO
UNTIL WE GET OUR PARTIAL
BIRTH ABORTION BACK.
WHAT EFFECT IS THIS GOING TO
HAVE ON AMERICA?
>> WELL, IT'S WEIRD TO ME
BECAUSE THE RATIONALE FOR
ABORTION, SUCH AS IT IS THAT
ABSTINENCE EDUCATION DOESN'T
WORK.
SO WE HAVE TO HAVE ABORTION
BECAUSE ABSTINENCE DOESN'T
WORK.
BUT ABSTINENCE APPARENTLY
DOES WORK WHEN ALYSSA MILANO
IS COMMANDING IT.
YOU JUST READ OUT THE TWEET.
IT'S ACTUALLY FANTASTICALLY
WORDED.
WE JUST CANNOT RISK
PREGNANCY.
JOIN ME BY NOT HAVING SEX.
SO, ON THE DAY THAT DORIS
DAY DIES, WE ARE BASICALLY
BACK TO THE SEXUAL MORALITY
OF DORIS DAY YOUNG AT HEART
CIRCA 1954 IN WHICH
HOLLYWOOD ACTRESSES NOW ARE
PROMOTING BECAUSE THE RISK
OF PREGNANCY FROM HAVING SEX
ARE TOO HIGH.
WOKENESS EVENTUALLY BRINGS
YOU BACK TO THE FAME DANK
SLUMBERS OF 60 YEARS AGO.
IT'S AMAZING.
>> Tucker: IF YOU WERE TO DO
A STUDY OF THE UNHAPPINESS
PEOPLE IN AMERICA, AND THEN
ISOLATE THE PEOPLE WITH THE
MOST INFLUENCE OVER OUR
SOCIAL POLICY, IT WOULD
BE -- THE UNIONS WOULD BE
100 PERCENT.
THE MORE UNHAPPY YOU ARE,
THE MORE INFLUENTIAL YOU ARE
OVER HOW PEOPLE LIVE THEIR
PERSONAL LIVES.
WHY IS THAT?
HOW DID WE GET HERE?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT'S WHAT
IS VERY INTERESTING.
A LOT OF THESE SO-CALLED
ACTIVISTS AND THIS IS A VERY
WEIRD REACTION TO A PIECE OF
PUBLIC POLICY.
IT CERTAINLY IS A LOT MORE
DRACONIAN THAN JUST TRYING
TO WIN A FEW LOCAL ELECTIONS
IN GEORGIA.
BUT AS YOU SAY, THE HAPPIEST
PEOPLE ACCORDING TO ALL THE
SURVEYS ARE ALL THE UPTIGHT
REPUBLICAN SQUARES GETTING
BORING OLD MARITAL SEX.
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY NOW
THERE ARE LITTLE PA JAMMY
BOYS WHO AGREE WITH ALYSSA
MILANO A LOT OF THINGS AND
SHE STILL WON'T LET THEM GET
TO SECOND BASE.
IT'S A TRAGEDY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: LIKE WHY IS IT --
IT'S SORT OF UNSPOKEN IN ALL
OF THIS IS THE IDEA THAT
HAVING KIDS IS LITERALLY THE
WORST THING THAT COULD
HAPPEN TO YOU.
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: LIKES THE END OF
WHATEVER YOUR STUPID CAREER
IS OR THE THINGS YOU THINK
ARE SO IMPORTANT IN YOUR
LIFE WHICH BY THE WAY MEAN
LITERALLY NOTHING IN THE
END.
WHERE DO WE GET SOME PLACE
WHERE A WHOLE POLITICAL
PARTY BELIEVES LIKE HAVING
CHILDREN IS LIKE A
PUNISHMENT?
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
THAT IS THERE WAS FIRST
BOOTED BY ASTAIR
BOOTED BY AAHAIR
BOOTED BY AAHISR
BOOTED BY AARISR
BOOTED BY AARISTOPHANES SEX
IS TRANSACTIONAL THING FOR
WOMEN.
BETTE MIDLER FOR EXAMPLE HAS
JOINED ALYSSA MILANO'S SEX
STRIKE TODAY.
I REMEMBER THAT -- I
MENTIONED DORIS DAY.
I REMEMBER THE OLD DORIS DAY
JOKE OSCAR I NEVER THOUGHT
WE WOULD LEARN LONG ENOUGH
FOR THE LINE I KNEW BETTE
MIDLER BEFORE SHE WAS A
VIRGIN TO BECOME A THING.
I THINK THEY DO NOT REALIZE
HOW DEEPLY WEIRD THEY SOUND
WHEN THEY INTERVENE ON
RATHER DULL MATTERS EVER
JUST ELECTING MORE OF THEIR
SIDE TO THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
INSTEAD OF DOING THAT THEY
ARE PROPOSING CRAZY IDEAS.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK
THEY CAN HELP IT?
>> I'M IN FAVOR OF MORE
CHASENESS.
IF ACTRESSES ARE BECOME
CHASED AS OPPOSED TO
TWERKING ALL OVER THE
SCREEN, THEN I'M FOR CHASED
ACTRESSES RATHER THAN
TWERKING ACTRESSES.
>> Tucker: ESPECIALLY IF THE
ARGUMENT IS WE ARE SO MAD WE
ARE GOING TO STOP
REPRODUCING.
OKAY.
>> YEAH.